hidden within this video will be five
Easter eggs referencing older videos on
this channel and if you do not catch
those references you are not a true fan
[Music]
uh first thing I want to be very clear
that opening was a joke please don't
drive yourself crazy combing through
this trying to find references to older
videos
well maybe I shouldn't have said that
because I'll probably just end up
rambling my self silly and people will
just find stuff that resembles stuff
I've said before anyway
that could have been engagement I blew
it dang my conscience
anyways I want to talk about continuity
and lore which are slightly different
but they are related and especially in
the manner in which I want to talk about
them today which is
asking the question
does continuity actually help
storytelling
or is it a hindrance
because
at a certain point continuity and trying
to maintain it
starts to really hamper what creative
people can do
let's back up a little let's actually
sort of just acknowledge that there is a
value to be had in continuity and with
lore with continuity
it's just nice to know that the stuff
that you have already engaged with that
you have some interest in that you are
committing to that you are you know
taking enjoyment from and spending your
time with that it's not just acting like
oh well forget about all the stuff
you've taken in before what we're going
to do has nothing to do with it it just
feels nice like your work is being
acknowledged and appreciated that you
have stuck around with the property for
however many books issues of a comic
entries in a film franchise television
sequels whatever for however long you've
been doing it
it can be rewarding to be like oh
it's nice that this is staying
consistent so there is some value in it
although to
um
slightly reword a quote from uh Yahtzee
croshaw
uh continuity is a little bit like
having access to adult entertainment in
a hotel room it's a nice thing to have
but if it's not there it's kind of hard
to explain why it's so important to you
and I want to distinguish between
continuity and serialized storytelling
because when you're dealing with a
Serial Story one designed from the
beginning to Be A Serial story that's
not really what I'm talking about
because if everything that we're
experiencing is intended to be multiple
chapters of a single continuous
narrative then yes there should be
continuity because this is all one story
so within say the Lord of the Rings
franchise yeah there should probably be
continuity between Fellowship of the
Ring and to two towers and then over to
Return of the King because that is one
narrative
so yeah there should be continuity and
it should be consistent
what I'm talking about is more how
necessary is it for The Hobbit to
maintain continuity with Lord of the
Rings for the silmarillion to maintain
continuity I mean it would be nice
but do we need it so I needed to make
that clarification because otherwise I
suspect the comments would have derailed
and like well what about all these
stories that are telling us we're not
talking about that I think something
like honestly comic books most superhero
uh well the original comic books and
superhero adaptations be they TV shows
or things like the MCU or the now
rebooted continuity of the DC movies I
sort of rebooted we'll see if flash ends
up being an actual full-on reboot or
exactly how that's going to work but
things like that
um or Star Wars does the continuity
help because a lot of those stories
exist independent of each other they're
within the same same setting they are
using the same characters and obviously
continuity is important insofar as
completely contradicting what came
before without some kind of
acknowledgment that something's changed
that feels like a mistake
when characters are inconsistent when
you aren't able to hold true to the
journey a character went through and you
just rolled them back to how they were
you know several stages back and
ignoring character development
things like Doctor Who get accused of
that you can take that with the
character of the master uh the previous
Incarnation before our most recent one
was Michelle Gomez as Missy who was a
character with an arc
I would hesitate to call it Redemption
but she was on a path to be better not
be the villain and then we have Sasha
Dewan who came after who is very much
just living his best villain life and
there's some distaste in that some
people taking it as well you just rolled
back her character development it's a
question of whether it's actually a
continuity problem because you're just
ignoring what came before of course
that's continuity in terms of character
Journeys and characterization there's of
course just the basic nuts and bolts
continuities such as you have a
character making use of an item that
they lost three stories ago so you know
if the Doctors Sonic Screwdriver is
destroyed
and then three episodes later he just
has it again well you probably should
explain why he's got that back because
otherwise
you just weren't paying attention
and while I don't agree with I don't
disagree with that
does it actually matter
here's the weird thing about continuity
continuity for a very long time
and lore by association I guess I'll
distinguish before I get into this point
lore is a bit more not necessarily
if that is actively in the stories we
are being told but this is all the
background information the World
building the history all the the ins and
outs of how the greater World works that
are not
necessarily particularly highlighted or
even brought up within the main
narrative themselves
so lore I'll just say up front I don't
care about Laura
I've never cared about Laura in my mind
and I'm not saying lore has no value but
me personally I'm not really in a good
position to judge lore because I don't
care
if your story is engaging me in and of
itself then maybe
I'll look a little into like the
background or the history of the world
or the setting or the other characters
but if you told me a really good story
then I'm just going to be happy with
that story
some people do like to engage with that
do like to look into the stuff but if
you ever create a piece of work that is
not fulfilling or doesn't make sense or
isn't rewarding unless you've taken in
all the lore or if you create like a
second or third entry in a franchise
that instead of just building directly
off the previous entries building off a
ton of lore that other people needed to
sink a lot of time into separate from
having taken in the previous work
that to me is a big problem
and I bring up Laura because it's going
to kind of feed into where I'm going
with explaining why continuity can be a
problem
but to the point I was making a minute
ago
continuity is a slightly weird thing
within fandoms because for a long time
knowing continuity at all
was kind of a mark of status
it was a real way to embody the level of
commitment to a fandom to know what
issue a superhero encountered a certain
person or acquired a certain item or the
first appearance of a certain villain to
know that stuff or to know the full
background of the silmarillion in the
entire history of Middle Earth and not
just know the plot of Lord of the Rings
was kind of
like I said a little bit of a mark of
status and it felt special because I am
old enough to remember the world before
the internet
and in the world before the internet
if you wanted to know about all the
other stuff that had gone on in Star
Wars after the Return of the Jedi you
had to read a lot of books
and there was a certain sense of
let's be frank superiority that some
fans had who had committed to all of
that
and whether or not that sense of
superiority is healthy for a fandom uh
it can get weird it can get gatekeepery
but I think it made a little bit more
sense to be
taking that pride in knowing continuity
in knowing lore back when you literally
had to do a hell of a lot of leg work
like why as we got into the 90s you
started to get like encyclopedias for
characters or settings but if it was a
continuing thing those are going to be
outdated in a year anyways but you know
there would be things like that in
certain but you'd still have to pay for
them you'd have to have access to them
and you'd have to buy them
and the internet kind of changed
everything
the internet even in its early days even
pre-google
you had tons of sights where fans who
did know this stuff were compiling all
the information making reference sheets
for all this stuff all the continuity
and now these days yeah basically any
continuity connection or mistake
it's a Google search away
you can look up a Wikipedia and if a
thing has been running long enough the
continuity errors alone will probably
have their own Wikipedia page
but
that makes it so
it's odd that many fans still latch on
to continuity the way that they do
when it's not really a mark of status
anymore
knowing the continuity
isn't really the same level of
commitment that it used to be
and again if you take enjoyment out of
knowing all that stuff over the top of
your head I'm not trying to take that
away from you I'm glad that that is how
you found a way to fulfill yourself and
feel rewarded with a fandom that's fine
that's terrific even
but
that brings me back to the question
how much does continuity actually matter
especially now because it used to be
like in a comic book in say the 80s
it used to be that when I minor again
minor continuity error not like oh I
forgot this character was dead or
something ridiculous like that but a
minor continuity error like wear a
character lives or how two characters
first met or something that ultimately
yes the fans know that because they have
access to all of the knowledge and the
information that they have read and they
have stored that upwards the writer
especially if they're a writer for hire
they're just coming in going off a you
know a series Bible and just going okay
and if any of that hasn't been updated
or there's a detail missing they don't
know it often so there's all that at
play with something like a comic book
and in like I said in the 80s or so
round about then
if a writer got something wrong it was
only going to be the hardcore fans and
the hardcore nerds who are ever gonna
notice
your average reader even if they
suspected something was off or was or
wasn't quite right what were they gonna
do read every issue to find out that
something was wrong now everybody can
catch continuity errors now by the same
token theoretically continuity errors at
this point should be easier to avoid
because this information is all
searchable
but that brings me to my ultimate
question that I want to ask with this
are we harming
the ability of storytellers to actually
tell stories
with an excessive focus on continuity
and short version
yeah a bit
one of the things about continuity is
it's cute and fun and enjoyable
certainly at first but the longer it
goes on it compounds the complexity
compounds the number of things that you
either have already done within the
narrative or you now can't do because
doing so would contradict something else
that has already happened or something
that has been established
it just makes it harder there's a reason
that many properties long-running
properties as they go on have a tendency
to get really repetitive
because the continuity and what's been
established and where things make sense
to go logistically and in terms of
character Dynamics
if it's just perpetuating
well
eventually there are going to be ideas
that creators have that like well I
can't do that
that just doesn't work
that's why you tend to get a lot of
rollbacks on things this is where
retconing comes in fundamentally
sometimes uh something gets retconned in
a story because well maybe it wasn't the
best idea in the first place but most of
the time
when something gets retconned uh if you
aren't familiar with the term it's
retroactive continuity when something
gets retconned it's generally because
the retcon is the only way to give the
Creator access to something they can't
otherwise do
so the classic example is if a villain's
dead
but the Creator wants to tell a story
with that villain again kind of pulling
from comic books
easiest way to do that is to just retcon
their death somehow or other now to
distinguish a retcon is not the same as
like the villain is brought back to life
with magic or Frankenstein science or
something no the retcon says oh no they
didn't actually die in the first place
and in some cases the retcon is less
egregious depending on the setting it
might be more reasonable to just be like
oh no you thought they died but they
didn't then to go and they are back from
the dead depends on the setting and
depends on the rules but that's the
thing
the more story you tell
the more rules get laid
and rules while they are guiding
they're also ultimately restrictive
and as I said this is a problem that
compounds because initially continuity
isn't really that big a problem but once
you start getting on to years and
especially in anything where the
property changes hands
there are reasons that reboots happen
in all forms of media
whether it be comic books whether it be
movies whether it be television
one of the reasons and like I said there
are multiple reasons but one of the
reasons to do a reboot
is that the continuity has become so
convoluted or so restrictive in terms of
what you can or can't do or what has or
hasn't been established and what you
feel you can actually work with or
whether you feel like you have so few
options or you have way too many options
because so much stuff now exists within
this world
rebooting
is the way to simplify that
I mean DC Comics and the crisis on
infinite Earths is kind of the classic
example because it was literally meant
to simplify the continuity
because up to that continuity in DC
Comics kind of existed by accident
initially characters
would occasionally like reference each
other or show up somewhere or they both
appear on the cover of an issue where
they don't actually appear together
they're in separate stories within that
issue but continuity started happening
as oh a neat thing we could actually
have these characters interact with each
other
but then you have to start creating
rules and whether you mean to or not
whether you actually sit down to
actually plan out the rules rules are
being created as you go just by the
nature of the stories that you tell
and to make sense of the rules that
didn't fit or didn't make sense
DC eventually created a Multiverse and
said okay look there's this universe
where this continuity is what's going on
there's this universe where this
continuity is what's going on and
there's also a bunch of others for the
random one-off continuities we've
created over the decades
and it was too complicated
it's also arguable that in that case the
reboot was also for the sake of new
readers not necessarily the existing
readers but new ones because it was
intimidating to come in and go wait why
does this comic have Superman with gray
hair and acting differently than this
comic where Superman's like in his 30s
because different continuity but if you
collapse all that down make it one
continuity and reset most of it well
you can start fresh and you can take it
in new directions and you can tell the
stories that the continuity didn't let
you tell
of course there's a lot of Hazards with
a reboot because one of the traps of a
reboot is just to end up retelling the
exact same stories again
and because you've eliminated
continuities suddenly oh well we have to
re-establish all this stuff so let's
tell Batman's origin for the fifth
freaking time even though it's the same
thing and it hasn't changed
so
continuity
ultimately
I think I got a side with Yahtzee on
this
it's a nice thing to have
but if it's not really there
it's hard to explain why it matters
again within the net the nature of
stories that come one right after the
other as opposed to a continuous
narrative
like maintaining continuity between
separated stories
it can be a nice thing
but it can also really bog you down and
this can go to the most basic and
simplest things
one of my favorite film series it's the
Thin Man series it's a series of uh
detective movies and they're awesome
they're wonderful the banter between the
two leads Nick and Nora Charles is s
tier legendary banter I love these two
as a couple
over there
what are you drinking right
yes that's yours
and in the third movie
it introduces a baby
and the baby's fine
but then they get to the fourth movie
and the baby's a little older
the fifth movie they made the wise move
of having the uh two leads basically on
vacation and having left the kid in the
care of somebody else but then the sixth
movie comes back and well
we established that they have a kid so
the kids got to come back and that kid
is
dang annoying in that sixth movie
and I suspect probably
most of the people making it didn't
really want to use that kid
but that was the continuity they'd
established the kid exists
and they're stuck with him
so
just that basic fundamental stuff
something that works as a one-off
suddenly you're stuck with
something that made sense to wrap up and
finish with suddenly you don't have
access to
and the possibilities for what you can
do just
it gets wonky
is there a solution to this no not
really
but I wanted to talk about it because
it's a problem that's compounded in the
world of
The Cinematic Universe these massive
sprawling continuities and all these
problems have existed in comic books for
ages
but they're now getting ported to other
mediums they're getting ported to
television they're getting ported to
movies they're getting ported to the two
things crossing over with each other
and
it's just difficult
to be able to move forward and it's
going to get harder
it's going to get harder and harder for
creators to be able to come up with
stories that excite them
that don't in some way
contradict the continuity or that they
are aren't told well you can't do that
because five movies ago eight years and
five movies ago we did this and that
doesn't really fit
if it's an idea you're passionate about
that's a quick way to lose your passion
and so again
I don't think continuity
is a wicked or awful thing but I think
especially fans who get really hung up
on the continuity
tend to
underestimate the impact continuity has
on creators especially in anything that
does not keep the same creative team
entry to entry
which is the case of pretty much all
these big sprawling franchises I'm
mentioning
continuity is something that
I'm going to be contending with in my
own way
eventually as I work through more novels
in my own series
and no promises on when any of these
will be out but it scares me
there's something very scary about
thinking I've made this story and it's
the story I want to tell and worrying in
the back of my head that somebody's
gonna pick up some little detail that
was mentioned in the first book where
they're gonna be like wait a minute
but that doesn't make sense and suddenly
I can't just tell the story I want to
tell
not without like coming up with an
explanation for why something doesn't
fit
that's a draining thought
and I think it'd just be nice if
folks could ease off a little bit at
least in some of the smaller things some
of the little details again if the
continuity is good that's great I love
when the continuity is seamless
but if it isn't
and it's not major and it doesn't
actually fundamentally alter the
characters or negate a story
consider letting it go
maybe I don't know
anyway that's my Ramble On continuity
and why it's
appealing but also kind of dangerous
especially again for anything that is
long running it's why stuff reboots all
the freaking time
well it's part of why
money's the other reason why but it
that you all know that what are your
thoughts on anything I've just gone on
about whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living if you supported me
there you would have seen this video in
advance and you also get access to
things like a patreon exclusive Discord
uh you could see my doctor for what I'm
planning to do at the start of every
month etc
etc etc
but don't worry too much about it if you
are not able to support me there there's
links in the description for other
things I do I mention my book there's a
link in the description if you ever want
to get a hold of that like share
subscribe also help but
I really want you to remember is that
you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
incontinuity or out of it
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
foreign my thanks to all my patrons but
in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin LED fulla Sarvis to rock the
thing that goes doing in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
leotha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
fernandby likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor goddess Elita
Elida not sure ah David Hall Shayla
Gourley Rosalind Bennett
you want to hear me mess up your name
too it's in the patreon perks
I gotta work on that
[Music]